hi everybody i'm eric and i'm i work for
the novice for kniver novartis is uh
research arm
uh i've made a lot of mistakes in the
past and i wanted to
um share some of my lessons from making
all of those mistakes
so uh if we could go to the next slide
please priyanka a
spacebar simple spacebar will do the
trick and then shift spacebar
will bring us back in case we need to um
so
the main just so that you have a little
bit of where i'm coming from
the the main object of my work
is to accelerate biological and chemical
research
we're hunting for medicines um there's a
molecule
or a class of molecules out there that
solves
diseases and we want to be able to find
them in a fast way
the hypothesis right now is that machine
learning methods will help us
and so i try to bring in principled
statistical workflow
as well as you know robust machining
work machine learning workflows
into my day-to-day work and
um so that's that's the main focus right
now if we go to the next slide
um that's where i oh
that is kind of weird
ah priyanka can you refresh the slide
deck please refresh the browser
sure because it would have uh i've
updated the slides with a git push
pretty recently so and that's me trying
oh no don't hit the right button hit
spacebar
just hit spacebar and that's good enough
yeah all right cool
so uh yeah i'm a data scientist and the
reason i've made all these mistakes is
because i've also had to play every
single
role that you can think of uh in a
science data science context
so we i work on protein engineering
projects so therefore
i've played protein engineer helped
design experiments with my bench
colleagues
i played data engineer because i was
part of a three-person
team that supported the development of
the project
we've had to build our own software we
then have to go on and decide
you know what what machine learning
methods we're going to use go and
benchmark them
we've had to deliver presentations um
and so that's that's sort of a little
bit of where i'm coming from
uh all of the mistakes that you can
imagine so if we go
down two slides uh just hit spacebar
twice
i wanted to talk about uh give a little
few words of encouragement
with respect to the open source world as
well because i myself have
benefited tremendously from it and i
want to make sure that
i encourage more people to contribute to
the open source world
in terms of where i come from what i
work on in the open source world
moving on to the next slide um all right
there's worked on with pie janitor for
example
um uh bianca if we could move to the
next slide please
no uh it's uh hit space please
just hit space bar uh you don't have to
use the mouse um
one of the things that i work with i've
helped develop is this package called
pyjanitor
it's sort of a package where we're
trying to
bring a much cleaner api to data
cleaning you know methods training and
the likes you can click on the link in
the slides if you want to check it out
uh it's very beginner friendly to
contribute uh there's there's a lot of
um
there's a lot of uh very user-friendly
functions that are inside there also the
the programming model is really easy if
you have a function
that you want to contribute it literally
is you implement the function
uh and then we'll help you we'll work
with you to make it like robust well
documented tested
all of that good stuff and it's actually
been my uh
training ground plus practice ground for
software development workflows which
have
really influenced how i uh do stuff
nowadays
going on to the next slide um uh
we'll see i i'm also really passionate
about
educating and teaching things and
network analysis made simple is an open
free project and i want to encourage
those of you who have
things you feel like you can teach
go and make these open teaching
materials open
educational resources because they're
really great
for uh one brushing up your own
knowledge
and two uh sharing the knowledge with
others and three
getting knowledge that you know stuff
out into the public domain
right and it's it's a really great way
if you're uh
inclined this way to to go and um
uh go and help build your
basically help build your public
portfolio so it's a great way to do that
on the next slide we'll see that uh
we're giving away two two copies of that
book
um so you can stick
if you stick to the end then uh there's
a chance to get a raffle
for it um and then uh
down one more slide beyond that uh if we
could move on priyanka
and one more down sorry um
there's another one that we're trying to
write it's all the lessons we've learned
me and another colleague zach uh he and
i have stumbled through it since grad
school we were in
grad school together um it's up on lean
pub
and if you'd like to read it uh there's
a sign up form on lean pub that can tell
that you can tell us like hey i'm kind
of curious about what's happening there
okay so if we move on uh i wanna
uh if you hit spacebar please the the
thing that we're gonna go through today
is what i call principal data science
workflow and it's basically everything
outside of importing cycle and building
your model like i'm assuming
if you're in a data science position
nowadays um
doing data summaries pulling data with
sql building models
building predictive and or causal models
and delivering
um delivering on
projects is is part of your day-to-day
but as i've learned from work there's a
whole
that's like the the core of what we do
but there's a whole
bunch of stuff outside the core that can
really accelerate
our work in the core but if we ignore it
then
we're going to be hampered in how fast
we can move
so the five principles that we'll be
going through today are
are really principles that relate to the
workflow outside of the core
right so first off you know um it's it's
about
starting with what a defined impact is
and going to look like the second one is
to
stick to pretty sane conventions that
are you know
human first conventions the third
is to develop in such a way that we're
not like
um we can move from computer to computer
you know we can we can develop in a
pretty portable fashion um and then the
fourth
is to really invest a lot in automation
and the final one is to uh be
very picky with defining sources of
truth because your data sources can get
for example your data sources can get
wildly out of hand if you're not careful
so um those are the five things we'll go
through
each of them has has uh been backed by
a lesson that i've learned in the past
all right
um if we go into the next slide one
thing that i just recently learned about
from the book uh in a different context
is this idea of
liebig's law of the minimum so how fast
your team will go is
not is dictated not by the total
richness of your environment but by the
limiting factor and it sort of makes
sense if you're
if you if you know anything about uh
plants you'll know that if there is
something that
limits its growth that's going to be
that's going to cap its growth
and it actually follows pretty naturally
from the laws of biology
what's your rate limiting reaction
what's your rate limiting step
right your your data projects think
about them in a holistic fashion there's
all these things that can help you make
your projects move faster be much more
robust uh
be all around better if you don't spend
time on them then you're just going to
be limited by
whatever is limiting the full potential
of your projects
so if we move on to the next slide
i want to go through a few screenshots
these are screenshots that are uh
snapshots of my past
and i want to engage a bit of dialogue
with you
uh when you look at these repositories
um so let's look at this first
repository on the next slide
right it's it's what uh it's a thing
from grad school
five years ago i did this project um
can i ask when you look at a repository
that looks something like this
what looks wrong to you can you put that
in the chat
yeah let's put that in the chat and then
tell me what looks wrong to you
so venkatesh has a
lack of organizational structure yes
absolutely
no hierarchy thank you lara it's a long
list of stuff you hit the viewer
with like oh stuff francis is telling me
i should have code packaging and sandy
goes i have no idea where to start
exactly that's that's really good you
picked up on it
um and ann had this
has this comment looks like you only did
one commit
basically yeah um published it and
didn't really
do use git at all exactly this is
me five years ago right we go to the
next slide
tell me what looks wrong here
in chat
this one's a little bit
not so obvious and unfortunately you
can't scroll down but you can look for
the repo if you want to
so ben's going organization notebooks
scripts etc
right so there's there's a little bit
more organization but it's still
lacking something right exactly
uh there's yeah so there's like there's
no there's
also you'll notice someone mentioned
library files there's no custom source
um which is well-defined that i can
install
uh i'm lacking a proper
full-fledged data science environment i
mean i have a requirements.txt but
it's not really used for anything and so
this is three years ago not five years
ago this is when i like got burned
by installing uh stuff into the system
python environment and then
promptly broke iphoto because iphoto
broke
when i deleted the system python
and tried to start over from scratch so
then i learned okay i should maybe use
an environment manager
picked up conda and started doing things
but even then good habits were not
necessarily ingrained
all right so if we go to the next slide
let's see uh
continue the critique what else is what
else is bad about this one
is very astute with that i'm missing
instructions
missing how to recreate the environment
the readme is kind of
uninformative exactly yeah it's another
snapshot from my past
so you can see and you know when i was
first and by the way i'm not shy about
this there's a reason why i'm i've taken
screenshots and none of these
repositories are private you can
actually go in and dig into my
history and find that i was once a
really bad
developer and i was once not so well
versed in all of these
best practices that i'm going to talk
about and that's
there to to hopefully ease the pressure
and give you a bit of encouragement
everyone starts somewhere so
uh and we're going to go through all of
those uh principles in a little bit more
detail but everybody starts somewhere
and everybody because they've started
somewhere they're going to have a
history that looks something like this
is completely fine
as long as you are on an upward
trajectory okay
all right so let's let's
let's go down two slides and and let's
take a look at this yes exactly that so
when you approach a new data project
what i find is
i've often times got a bunch of
questions
um to which by the way all of the
examples that i showed
above they will be negative they will be
negative answers so let's
let's take a look at and see it once
what some of these questions
are right so we go to the next slide
that first
question we might ask is we hit a
repository and we're going like well
okay where are
these things located where is the
jupiter notebook right
where is the custom source code where's
the documentation for the project
if you might be wondering why am i so
why do i keep harping on
the custom source code piece well
there's a reason for that
with the custom source code
imagine you wrote all of your stuff in
databricks notebooks
right the databricks ui i'm not sure
whether you've
experienced it before but i have it
encourages all of your user-defined
functions to be
inside the notebook and what does that
incur what does that mean for the
readability of the notebook
the notebook is essentially unreadable
so you need a custom source code package
and notebooks like python code are
intended to be read
and if you're going to make things
difficult for a person coming into your
project then it's
it's kind of defeats the purpose right
of writing notebooks
so um in any case that's why i'm so
insisted on custom source code and
building a python library that supports
the project
and more generally i want to know where
are the notebooks where's the custom
source code
where's the documentation for the
project and where's all these other
things
right if we go onto the next slide
another question that i might have
when it comes to data project is i'm
curious to know
what the latest status of the analysis
is right
where is the dashboard or web app that
powers
that sorry serves up not power serves up
the analyses results
even if it's in spot fire where can i go
and take a look at where it's located
um and i another thing i want to know is
uh the thing that i might see on a
dashboard
of some kind or a web app of some kind
um
are the analyses up to date you know
those things up to date with respect to
the latest data how can i go back in
and track and see without needing to
bother people too much
what the latest status updates are if
you adopt
tooling such as continuous integration
tooling you can actually get a
programmatic way
of knowing when knowing some of these
answers
moving to the next next thing as some of
you
um correctly pointed out
there are no instructions to you know
recreate the environment
re uh uh and launch a jupiter notebook
uh and you know be able to re re-execute
things
so you know that's one of the things i
want to look for where
is the environment.yaml file right if
there's an environment.yaml file
immediately it's it's extremely
idiomatic what i'm supposed to do
or even if if you know you have things
that are a little bit more complicated
and you need more than just what conduct
can provide you
where's the docker file right even with
a dockerfile there's a standard set of
idioms that are provided that make it
very easy
for a newcomer to the project who is
also well-versed in a bunch of
these community idioms to come in and
recreate the environment and start being
productive pretty
pretty quickly and even better where is
the one or two line bash
uh command right that's sort of the
convenient stuff that you want to
provide here to your future selves or to
other colleagues
moving on there are more questions
there's data involved sometimes your if
your data
file is small enough you can
commit your data inside the git repo i
don't think always
encourage that i think there's there's
got to be better ways for data storage
um but in a pinch if you really needed
to and you wanted the entire project
to be portable from computer to computer
you can just
put a small csv file inside there uh
and and and that's cool but then if
you've got stuff that's on s3
or in a database where the instructions
that tell you how i should get
access to the data right where's the
parquet file that i should be targeting
right um how do i get the necessary
access that these documentation pieces
ought to be inside there too um and then
if we go on
there's another question how do i know
if you've got custom source code
inside your project um so we move on to
the next slide
i've got custom source code inside the
project how do i know it's correct
right did you how do i know how to use
it
your test suite will tell me but how
uh if you don't have a test suite how am
i supposed to know uh
if you write if i see copy pasted
functions
from one notebook to the next how am i
supposed to know
whether the intent here was that they're
supposed to do the same thing
or they're actually different things
it's really hard to tell
right without closely examining the code
but if you have a custom source library
you can install flags you know that uh
help you modify the behavior of the
function in a very principled fashion
uh and make it much easier for someone
coming in to like
read your notebooks okay so uh
those are the set of questions and they
all come from
like me going into another project and
then
realizing oh shucks i don't know what i
was supposed to do or me
looking at a previous project that i
worked on
and then coming back to it you know half
a year or a year later and going like
ah crap i um totally forgot what i'm
supposed to do
to like recreate the environment um i
don't think i trust my source code and
more than once at work
i've actually rewritten projects from
scratch and
because they weren't done the right way
they weren't done in such a way that i
could come back later
and pick up on it i think we under
appreciate that
so let's talk about the principles
the principles we start with the first
one which is
um this notion that it's really
important to define impact like
modeling work uh at this point if you're
using tools like pi carrot and the likes
or auto sklearn um modeling work is the
least of your
your problems uh
getting the biggest source of
frustration for data scientists that
i've seen is that
we work on models and no decisions are
taken
on the basis of it we work on models
and the artifact there's no artifact
that we
deliver and hand over so the first
principle really is to define impact and
i have personal stories for me if you go
to the next slide
about three or four years ago i wrote a
graph neural network
uh that operated on protein structures
trying to predict
hiv drug resistance and that thing went
nowhere
because i didn't start with what do i
really want to achieve
like it remained as source code in a an
anonymous git repository
on my uh on my github user account
and um it just went nowhere i did stuff
i
did a whole bunch of stuff i granted
learned a lot of things about
how to implement graph neural nets from
scratch
and it gave me a very very deep heads
first education
in that but i have nothing to show for
that
and that's because i didn't work
backwards
starting with a defined impact so if we
go to the next slide
the thing that you want to take away
from this project from this principle is
always always define what the impact
looks like before you
embark on a project so the things that
you
questions that you will want to uh ask
yourself
for example on the next slide what
decisions
will we take on the basis of this
analysis
and on the basis of building a model
nowadays i actually challenge my
colleagues
first sure i can build a model but i'm
not going to build it if it's not going
to influence the experimental design
or the prioritization of molecules at
the bench okay
so what decisions or actions will be
taken
in addition to that if you go to the
next slide
we have to worry about what the artifact
looks like and and here's why
worrying about what the production
artifact work looks like
matters when you hand over an artifact
that brings
closure if you don't hand over an
artifact
there's probably an order to two orders
of magnitude
less feeling of closure so
when production so if you have if you
get a chance
to hand over an artifact that's
that's that's a great way of bringing
closure to the project it allows you to
say there's this contract defined
handover i'm going to give you stuff
and then i can move on and worry about
other interesting projects
at work and that's really what a data
science team i think should be
how they should be operating right like
it's it's a service organization
come in do one thing uh help bring it to
where that artifact needs to be
delivered
deliver it over to the supporting
organization or the client organization
and then move on to other really
interesting and cool problems
or at least that's what my team looks
like and how i would approach
uh what the team that i'm on looks like
so what do we mean by
different types of artifacts right does
it mean you build an api
right so if you build an api and hand
that over that is a
superb thing right um because for
example you might need
to build an api such that the software
engineering team
and machine learning engineering team
can build
other products into their like software
into the software that they're making
for you know other colleagues or
externally
if you go to the next one it could be a
software library
right that has been part of the things
that i've
had to deliver to other colleagues so
for example
working on this protein engineering
thing we've built a custom software
library and we're seeing
that parts of that library are actually
really useful to other colleagues doing
protein science
and so we can actually break that out
into a shared library
start advertising it hand it share it
with the others they can install it onto
their own condo environments
um and and do stuff with it right
um it can be a dashboard this is pr the
next one
is is dashboard and it can be something
that this is
pretty much what we consider to be the
um
canonical thing i put it in the middle
because i found this to be a little bit
too
bland for my taste nowadays uh
dashboards all fine and cool but
if there's if they're not making
decisions on the basis of your dashboard
it also is not
not that good but anyways so it's a form
of an artifact that you can deliver
as well lo and behold it can actually be
the case that
the excel spreadsheet is the output
and don't underestimate excel like i
forgot so much of excel that in front of
my accounting colleagues
they think i've got python wizardry i
think they have excel wizardry
they know how to do so much stuff in
excel and excel is like the
the one place that is readily available
for non-technical colleagues to be able
to really quickly dive into the data and
have
productive conversations with us right
and sometimes that's necessary and if
that means you need to
export an excel spreadsheet and hand
that spreadsheet over that's a totally
legit
endpoint as well and guess what i found
out as well
apparently an rstudio i'm a python
person but in our studio
there's this ability to generate emailed
reports
that get sent automatically from the
rstudio server into
uh your leadership inbox and if that's
the end point that they need
and you've mutually agreed on it
apparently the tooling also exists to do
that
okay so those are just examples
of some of the kind of outputs
and if you know if you see the pattern
here
the model code is sort of the core but
there's a whole bunch of supporting
python code or r code that you have to
write
in order to make this deliverable a
reality
so surrounding a data science project if
you go to the next slide
this really important point here is that
the surrounding the data science
project is often just a bunch of
software
that sometimes we have to write to fit
the context that we're in
and if we're going to write all of this
software
we might as well learn some cool things
from software developers who've had over
20 30 years
of modern software development modern
maybe five or ten
but 20 30 years of like learning lessons
that i think we data scientists can
learn from
right um i recently
picked up a book called i think it's
called shape up or something like that
it's it's linked
in in the slides if you mouse over that
it's a book that's geared towards
software teams
but it's it's a free book that like
really
really illustrates some of the really
good workflows it's written by the base
camp
uh base camp leaders um
jason and david jason freed and dhh
right there are some really cool ideas
inside there
data teams will need to adapt some of
those ideas they're not 100
transferable like mock-ups for example
uh less
less um uh less relevant to us
but sure that's that's something that
we'll have to adapt
um there's another thing that uh i
learned from another friend of mine
who who is a software engineer at
celerity
if you go to the next slide he he
advocates that we work
he advocates for developing software
outside in
or working backwards from the end point
to the core that's because the core
of any data problem or sorry of any
software problem
even though it's the most intellectually
intellectually interesting piece
it's oftentimes also not the most
impactful until it's connected way out
to you know how people are going to use
that piece of software
so in our case it's in a machine
learner's case for example
the api might be one really important
piece that we have to worry about if
we're not using frameworks
um with or the excel spreadsheet and you
know how we get from our machine
learning model to the output that our
end users want
that that really really matters so
working backwards is that principle and
there's a blog post that he
he uh also put in there and one other
lesson that i've learned
is that uh from for example this graph
neural net thing that i did in grad
school
the most complex model is not always
needed you should deliver on
the thing that's needed first before you
go back and try to improve it
and then even then you should go and
weigh the pros and cons of like in terms
not only in terms of model predictive
accuracy
but also in terms of is it worth the
extra complexity for example
to go and take on a deep learning
project
if the if sorry to convert the
model piece which is like the
intellectually interesting piece
into a deep neural net because if the if
practically speaking
you gain a small amount but of of
predictive accuracy which
translates to a small amount of uh
you know revenue or time saved is it
really worth
your large amount of time to go and
practice that if you're really looking
for a deep learning project
stay patient there's always going to be
something interesting
for which this trade-off becomes the
right trade-off
uh where you can invest a lot you might
improve the model a little bit but you
get
a hundred fold improvement in your
revenue or time saved or whatever
okay so in that's that's just one other
thing to
to worry about um okay so
yeah let's i actually just said all of
the stuff
that's on the slides coming up so we can
hit the right arrow button priyanka
so let's let's look at the second
principle the second principle is to
worry about conventions
uh that first principle was start from
the outside in
second principle is worry about
conventions what do i mean by
conventions
um i'm gonna take you through an example
um if we
go to the next slide i have if i have a
project
a really same convention is that
everything related to that project
belongs in one
directory right and that one project
because it's one directory it belongs to
one git repository on the next slide
okay so one project one one directory
one directory one git repository moving
on
if you have one project you have one
conda
environment okay and then if you have
one
conda environment or one project then
you have one
custom source package for that project
and why do you want that
source code package again on the next
slide i say it you want to minimize code
duplication
single source of truth easier to test
basically
you're right if you want to make things
a lot more
sane to manage as the complexity of your
project grows okay
if you write good software you'll find
that we're also
writing well-defined categories of
things yeah if you think
clearly about your software you actually
have a collateral benefit which is
you think a lot more clearly about your
project
as a whole as well give you an example
data loading functions
are a thing for me right um and with
data loading
functions with this protein engineering
project that i worked on
i could have just stuck all of my data
loading functions inside one dot pi
file instead no we chose to separate it
out by
our data modalities so we have the mass
spec data on one side
the sequencing data on another in
another.pi file
we and then all of the related helper
functions all
organized well over there so actually
when it comes to like
we're us categorizing bringing same
categories into our project
and then organizing our code in that
particular fashion helped us actually
reason about our project a lot much
a lot a lot more easily so moving on
when you have one project we've got a
custom source
package but yeah we also need one
notebooks directory
right and in fact in the notebooks
directory one thing we've done
is uh set up sort of like pseudo user
spaces like i have a notebook directory
under
the notebooks directory that belongs to
myself and i don't touch my colleagues
ones even though we can see each other's
right it's it's a pseudo user space sort
of thing
that helps us keep the notebooks from
cluttering the top level directory
moving on if you go to if because we
have one source directory we
have one test suite that tests
all of our code right i'm not going to
go through in detail how to do that over
here i've got another talk that i did
this year
earlier this year at ann arbor that goes
through how do you do testing practices
for data scientists
um but yeah you want something you want
to if you write code you should test it
if you write data loading functions you
probably should validate
that your data loaders work correctly as
well
moving on if you have one project you
should have one readme
and that one readme gives a newcomer to
the project
the overview of what they expect to see
right
um and then if if we move on again
with one project there's also one
documentation suite
right so uh these docs are written
essentially as markdown files there's a
bunch of tooling opinionated tooling
that give you the ability
to to make very beautiful documentation
sites network analysis made simple
is actually an example of me getting
practice with documentation
if you look at the site for network
analysis made simple we won't go there
right now but if you go there it's like
make docs material
it's got search it's insanely it's it's
organized there's a table of contents
um and everything renders in beautiful
html
so that's another thing so if we if
you're
wondering well like okay do i have to
remember
how to do all of this the first time
round
uh oh sorry every single time the answer
is
possibly but if you go to the next slide
there are cookie cutters
that allow you to create these projects
in a quick and easy fashion see and and
by the way if you master how to
uh wrangle one say for example cookie
cutter
uh that tool then it'll actually help
you
to customize it to the level of
complexity that you need
and you don't have to be stuck then with
someone else's extremely opinionated
cookie cutter
um there's a tool i've been trying
recently which is kedro
i personally think it's it tries too
much to be a god tool but i can see
where it's used
case might be so it's not lightweight
enough for my tastes
but i can see where other people might
find it handy
and you can i'd encourage you to go
check it out
moving on so that's principle two which
is
to worry about sane conventions and if
you'll notice it's
essentially a very strong one to one to
one to one to one
to one to one mapping of stuff one
project one get one docs one source one
test
one readme etc the next thing i wanna
talk about is this idea this notion of
being able to develop
portably and what do i mean by that if
we move on to the next slide
the essential essential idea here
is that you want to be able to work on
any machine
you don't want to be able you don't want
to be confined to just your laptop and
and i can tell you why
because there'll be times when you want
to access bursty compute
if you use das for example it'll let you
if you use das on a machine that has
access to
a compute cluster you actually can use a
tool called das
job queue to spin up an ad hoc 500
worker
compute cluster just for yourself that
lives on the high performance
compute cluster and use that to do
to take down workloads that may have
taken a few hours
to mere seconds right so das is really
really
important and and if you want to be able
to
if you want to be able to to work on any
environment then you need to
think portably so you might yes you
might start for example
on your little laptop i'm on my little
macbook or
you know my macbook pro that's my work
machine
but at some point i know that i'm
probably going to need bursty compute
and i'll want to be able to move the
project
onto a linux workstation that lives on
on campus at work that has the ability
to burst
into the high performance compute
cluster
so
that's one of the motivations and if you
go to the next slide the other
motivation here
is that if you develop your project to
be
portable on any machine the end product
that you might
have to develop so for example the api
or
for example uh this dashboard
it has a chance of also being portable
across any machine so you can actually
deploy to the cloud if you need to
or you can deploy it's an on-prem server
if you need to you're not going to be
confined
by all the quirks and uh
all the quirks that you might have about
your your local laptop
environment all right so moving on the
next slide
one of the important things that you
will want to consider is like putting in
a sane baseline environment file right a
conda environment file
i actually have this inside textexpander
so i do semicolon env and then bingo
i'll get this
this entire thing put out to my
text editor immediately and that gives
me a bunch of tooling that's pretty sane
right so i have the basic data science
stack
um i got code quality utilities i've got
stuff that's
you know good for documentation all
inside there and i can modify
and update the environment as the
project requires it
so that's one example um
if you so one limitation of condo
environment files is that they don't
worry about the operating system
tooling so if you're operating sys if
you do need things that are like
operating system-wide
then on the next slide is the solution
you probably need a docker file right so
i've seen projects
uh i think emily we worked through
things for your insight project as well
where there are some system-wide
libraries that were needed you couldn't
obtain by conda
at that point now you need to worry
either about the deployment system or
you need to worry about a docker file
so you can containerize the entire
project together
right so if we go down two slides um
that's like a basic thing i've actually
started
in fact experimenting with what we call
what software developers call
development environments it's still a
little rough right now for
um uh sorry development containers it's
still a little rough
for data scientists and that uh you know
starting a jupiter server and like
worrying about ports from the container
and that like that's still kind of a
little bit of a rough thing
but in terms of at least packaging up
the code such that it can be shipped and
handed over say to a software
engineering team
to for the full official
productionization this is like
going to lubricate your interaction with
them long term
all right all right so then
moving on to the next principle it's
all about automation so i
i wonder how many of you have had this
situation where for example
you get your notebooks are written
and now in order to
check the correctness of your analysis
you have to manually step through
the notebook sell by cell and like
visually inspect
did i does it sort of kind of look right
does the output look right did did i
accidentally change this function such
that it does the wrong thing
um that's human time that's being spent
that should be spent early on but you
should automate that so you don't have
to spend that human time
long term right or how about that other
one where
i actually got data from colleagues
twice
once in grad school once at work where
the csv file came in
and all of my code broke as the new csv
file came in
because suddenly they decided to
capitalize the column names right
that's the sort of thing that we don't
want to um we don't want to check
right um by hand we want we want a
machine
to be able to catch all of these things
on an automated basis
so that's why this fourth principle is
all about like
automation investing on automation will
help with reproducibility
and saving your time in the future so if
we take a look
um doing things like saving keystrokes
um mental shortcuts those dividends help
later on
and if you we look at a few examples um
one of my favorites is actually using
make files so if you uh on the next side
i got a few
few interesting few things you can do
with
make files um
so for example if i write a make file
that has an init command then i can just
do make init and it'll
execute all of the bash scripts that are
inside that block um sometimes pi test
if i have a
complicated testing suite command
i don't want to remember it i just want
to remember make test
then it'll do that in fact there's a
command that i wrote that
is called make format i didn't put this
one here but it's like
uh i sort so i sort all of my imports on
my python source files
and then black black with l 79 79
characters
for the win um and and and that
basically is is me saving time
and saving my colleagues time as i try
to onboard them onto the project
uh and so these little pieces of
automation they're worth it they're
absolutely worth it
um yeah so so that's that's and and one
of
their they're worth it because they make
these complex bash commands easy to
execute but also because
if you connect them with a pipelining
tool on the next slide
they actually make your pipelining tools
a lot pipelining declarative commands
a lot easier to to write so if you go to
the next slide you'll see it
you can have for example on travis
instead of having to remember and copy
paste like oh
uh i need to write pi test minus
minus vv dash dash cove and then blah
blah i can just
right there make tests and it's the same
command on my computer
it's the same command on a remote
machine um that
so that travis or azure pipelines or
jenkins
would use um
the the the real thought behind all of
this by the way
is on the next slide if a project if
you've got a defined
production endpoint i want to make sure
that everything has to be reliable
and in order to make sure but but
checking
that everything is reliable is a really
tedious
task right it's essentially saying this
should have been
as i saw it before this should have been
as i've seen it before
that other thing should have been as i
saw it before
why not automate it all why not save
yourself keystrokes
right so if we move on there's another
thing that another idea that i really
want to
share with uh try to champion and
encourage more people
to embark on which is this idea of
writing tests
for your data it comes back to that
column names thing
experience that i had before um where
i i had data that came in with the wrong
with badly spelled column names uh their
data that came in
that were in excel or csv files that
had like were miscalculated because
someone updated the excel spread
spreadsheet formulas um
and and that that just caused a lot of
disaster
downstream it caused a lot of things to
go to null values
completely unexpectedly so writing tests
for your data is really important and as
i've studied more and more about
bayesian stats
i come to realize how data are drawn
from a distribution
that distribution is extremely messy
it's not one of your nice parametric
distributions
your data come in with null values with
misspelled things
go see how many ways americans fail to
spell philadelphia the right way it's
all over
linkedin um so if you go on the next
slide branca
these things can change under you and
break in completely unexpected ways so
you better have a
well-defined source of truth that allows
you to automate
the checking of your data and so one of
the things that i've
encouraged before on the next slide is
simple data tests
so if you have data loading functions
you write a test
say for example for the column set you
can do other things for the data types
um if you don't want to do just the
hacky things
moving on to the next slide you can
actually try things out with pandara
pandera is pretty nice because it allows
you to validate your data in in a very
nice api i'm going to write a blog post
about this pretty soon
um so you can do schema validation so
for example if you have a data frame
that looks something like this
you go to the next slide you can
actually write
a pretty sane data frame
validation schema um and then use the
schema
object as you can see at the bottom to
validate against
new versions of the data frame that come
in right because you've declared in
python code
exactly what your data are supposed to
look like what you expect about that
data
and you can validate them at in with
python codes you can use them for
example
in test suites if you go down one slide
you can use them in you can use the
schema inside your
test suite as i'm showing over here so
we call this test time validation
or you can do it in like run time so for
example
as you load the data they'll come in and
you'll do other stuff
with it and and you want to validate
that the data are correct before you do
that other stuff
so pandaras there's the link for it
great expectations is another tool
i actually got in touch with the great
expectations developers early in the
year
after ann arbor we did a call
they did have they were gearing a
slightly different use case
i think it was more data engineering-ish
so
that that that call didn't really pan
out and then pandara came along from the
scipy
from the scipy talks this year and that
was amazing it was super
super exciting for me to see that
now if we go on there's still some more
that you can do with respect to
automation i've hinted at this before
you have uh continuous integration
tooling from the
software development world they can do
things like
automatically executing tests if you go
onto the next slide ci systems can be
also repurposed
to programmatically execute notebooks
you can do things like jupyter nb
convert
and add an execute command on that as
well
and if your notebooks are something you
depend on then you should probably
automatically execute these analyses and
then if you go on to the third thing
like ci systems if you need
to continually update these
model artifacts like your pickle files
or
excel spreadsheets or these dashboards
that you're building
like streamlet dashboards or uh plotly
dashboards or
panel dashboards you can actually
leverage a ci system such that
you've got everything sort of worked out
correctly and then you get
push to your repository
origin and the ci system will pull in
the latest changes
once you've programmed it once it just
works forever
assuming of course your computer
infrastructure doesn't doesn't
uh fall underneath you uh which is
has happened with um my our devops team
before
but i forgive them they they're under a
lot of stress there's security issues
they have to worry about and their time
is being sucked
but anyways i digress so that's the
fourth principle
investing a lot of like shortcuts
automation
saving from everything as small as like
saving keystrokes at the computer
to things as big as like system-wide
where you just have an automated runner
continually running and checking stuff
continually building stuff and exporting
stuff for you
super important piece of like helping
your
data projects run faster in the long
term
and the final thing i want to ask
encourage about
the fifth principle of defining a single
source of truth
what do i mean by that so here's some
examples on the first slide
uh under here one source library so
one defined source of truth for a
particular function that does stuff
don't copy
functions from one notebook to the next
to the next and then lose track
of which one is the actual one that you
want to rely on
right second example of this no copies
of data wherever possible if you need a
cache
it's got to be like in this place where
where
uh you know you don't trust that cache
to always be
the most up to date but as far as
possible minimize the number of copies
of your data
um here's the next one uh is one that
really
gets me going as far as possible
don't have your colleagues if your
colleagues are trying to be kind-hearted
and save you time
by offering to oh yeah i can just
calculate a new
excel file for you and it's derived off
that first excel file
and i'll just do this extra calculation
for you and and give it to you
as far as possible try to turn them down
there they've got good intents but it's
going to lead to
messy provenance of which data source
you're supposed to trust
for certain pieces of uh data and it's
happened before
where we've had a proliferation of csv
files and i go back and i can't remember
which csv file came from which other csv
file
and then i look at the two csv files and
then realize oh one's just
a pivot of the other why why did we
even bother creating a new data source
we should have just done the pivot in
memory live every single time
it's faster that way it's easier to keep
track of right so
it's great for prototyping but you
should very quickly offer to translate
all of that stuff into python code
so that your colleagues don't have to
give you mess
so that you don't end up with a tough to
provenance source of
data the next one
is one of my favorites if you have
defined data sources
then i would also encourage you to
develop shortcut functions to data this
this is a tip that like workflow piece
that straddles both
the fourth and the fifth principle so if
you have a data source
and you know that it takes two or three
transformations to get to another
form of the same data i would encourage
you to write functions
that do some stuff uh first off write
data loading functions and then write
other functions that build upon that and
give you x
to give you a shortcut to the
transformed piece of data let's see an
example of this
so on the next slide you'll see here is
some very
here's a data loading function that says
let's load some raw data
we'll pull in a file from the internet
because that's probably how it's
supposed to work
or if it's on your shared file system
you load it from there
um it's actually pd.read csv my
apologies i didn't even write that
properly
let's move on not trying to hide that
but look at that so
the raw data might be really important
but then there might be some transformed
data that also really matters
and you might have to do some
transformations on the data
before you can use it for a particular
purpose
and what you can do here then is write a
shortcut function a python
function that gives you a shortcut to
that data now i've
i've experienced this with my intern
he and i uh have tried
managing uh sql views i don't know if
you've tried doing that
that's a that's a pain right and if you
want to update the sql view
suddenly you have to like recalculate
everything and it's like just
crazy but then we realized our data is
small enough
that we could just cache them locally
and then write
data loading functions on top of the
cache and then just
program our computers to
automatically refresh the cache every
night right
every night we pull in a fresh copy of
the data and then
suddenly we went from worrying for
entire
hours of the day about whether we got
the sql view query correct
to just managing python pandas code join
it this way
drop this select a bunch of columns
bingo we're done now suddenly we have a
python function
that gives us a shortcut to that data
we've we've like gone from hours to like
minutes of development time um so these
shortcuts
help a ton and they help a ton not only
for
acts speeding up our productivity uh
they
they also provide a catalog a defined
source of truth um my
data.pi file which contains this
function that you're seeing on the
screen
will also contain docs strings that tell
me
the provenance of the data why the data
transforms were done
what the intended use of the data frame
is so it's a very nice and lightweight
um lightweight catalog of relevant data
frames that are important for the
project okay
so that's another piece that i want to
encourage you all to try
there are other tooling for that as well
so for example intake is an
alternative and it works on a little bit
larger scale so if you're not like on a
single project with three people
oh my this is gonna get noisy pretty
quickly one moment
a robot just started let me
send it back let me pause it for a
moment my apologies
there we go kedrow is also
in in part of this like uh trying to
work
sorry the kendrick devs also worry a lot
about like data provenance
pipelines and all that good good stuff
so you can see how
um what i'm suggesting
can be perceived as a bit hacky and i
totally
totally acknowledge that kedrow tries to
be a bit more principled
if you're willing to invest the the
five or so days to like learn kedrow it
does take about that amount of time as
i've personally experienced um and you
find it's going to be worthwhile that
trade-off is going to be worthwhile
um then by all means go for it but if
you're not willing to do that right now
there is a very lightweight practice
that you can already adopt it's data
loading functions with data tests
moving on there's you should be one you
should be providing one source for
documentation
so you people don't have to go to this
confluence page
to that sharepoint site to this markdown
file to that other piece on the web you
provide
one a piece on the internet you provide
one
authoritative source of documentation
for the project
even better if it's version controlled
and in that way it makes it so much
easier
for a newcomer to come in and figure out
where all of the relevant pieces of that
project are
so in terms of docs generators if we
move on two slides down
there's my favorite nowadays which is
make docs plus make docs material
uses markdown primarily
you can use sphinx if you're a little
bit more well-versed with that
it's taken me a little bit of time to
learn sphinx so
i don't recommend it as like the
beginner piece but if you want to be
pretty lightweight
um then you can use make dogs for
example
um i definitely encourage you to include
doc
documentation builds as part of your ci
pipeline so
if you do that then your docs are always
going to be up to date
and in fact if you use make docs
material you can get beautiful websites
like what i show below
network analysis made simple is one
example it's got search
it's got plots executable notebooks that
you can
view the outputs of on the next slide as
well
sorry so so
those are those are really cool and just
to tie things back
i want to go back to like uh if you go
to the next slide
there's this one line that gives you
the the docs build and i just include
that line
as part of like my local building of the
dock so i can preview it
and remote building of the docks so we
can see it on a remote machine
or on a ci pipeline okay so
moving on may sound like
holy smokes there's a lot right
like damn it am i supposed to do
everything
tomorrow and my encouragement to you is
no you don't what i want to encourage
you to do is to pick up
one practice and let that habit build
over time
keep in mind it's taken me five years
since grad school
to come to the point where i think some
of the
software tooling from sorry it's taken
me five years since grad school
to slowly incorporate more and more
software development practices that have
actually accelerated my work
don't tell anybody at work i hope nobody
at work is
attending today but i actually find a
lot of time
to slack off because i'm not worrying
about checking things by hand
right i i can dedicate my brain power to
more
interesting problems like well graph
neural nets
that's that's what really occupies my
head nowadays
um and i don't have to think so much
about like the nitty-gritty because i've
just automated
all of that stuff away um and
and so by adopting these
workflow practices into your data
science projects
they build up over time you find that
the amount of work that you can handle
because you've abstracted away and
automated away and and and just made
uh habitual these good practices
um they really elevate the amount of and
and quality of work that you can deliver
okay let's go back to liebig's law of
the minimum it's on the next slide
i'd say that this law
i've come to realize does really apply
to our data projects
um there are things that are going to be
rate limiting
for us and for us rate limiting really
means
time limiting so if you move on um
your project it's really going to move
as far
as fast or as high as the biggest factor
rate limiting it will limit it okay so
if we go two slides down i want to ask
encourage you to ask these questions
that really prompted my exploration into
you know all of this tooling it was
asking the question what slows me down
am i manually checking stuff all the
time oh
nah there's there's something that i
probably could write uh that automates
all that
drudgery away so anyways there's
probably if if there's something that
slows you down there's probably a
software development practice
that you can adapt so for example next
slide
manually checking the same things
automate it with a script write a python
function
two slides down from this slide uh data
issues failing you
automate your data validation checks
right um
are do you have unstable copy pasted
code well
maybe you should refactor your code so
that you can have this
and test it so that you can have the
guaranteed
sanity that your code is working um
is your environment like really hard to
reproduce because you installed this and
you installed that and you forgot what
you kept track of
um uh you're forgetting what what
you you need to install things well
declare it with an environment file
right write these declarative files that
are lightweight that help you manage
that complexity um moving on can you
remember
are you forgetting how to do things well
that's why doc's exist in fact
that's why blogs exists right because if
you forgot how to do something and you
learned how to do something sorry if you
learned how to do something first time
round
you immediately write it down and you
publish it as a blog whether internally
or externally
then you get a way to one raise your own
profile
to help others with their work and
accelerate their work
and then if you add that into the
documentation the source of truth
documentation for your project
then you make it really easy for
newcomers your
to your to your code and your project to
be able to
uh follow up on and and jump on with
minimal fuss
okay so those are the principles
they're on the slide i'm not gonna go
read them anymore
now uh there is an faq that i always get
that i really want to
go through so that i don't get these
questions in the q a
so if we go on to the next slide
priyanka and so the first one is
an objection that i always hear i don't
have time to adopt all of these
practices
my response to that is well sorry you
will have even less time and many more
fold stress if you don't
and trust me i've been there before and
it's really not a good feeling
for which the next question that comes
in is where do you find the time to
adopt these practices well like i said
before
you build them in one by one you find
the small wins
uh for the relevant pieces you build
those wins into your
into your workflow you get that win you
have an extra
chunk of time where you can breathe uh
and you can deliver stuff of higher
quality
you get back uh you get back that time
manifold and you get
what i call credibility points and this
is related to the next point
so your clients for example won't give
you the time
maybe to adopt these practices whole
sales what do you do then
again it's all incremental and it
relates to credibility points you
deliver what they want first
gain some credibility points and
reinvest those credibility points
on asking for time to build reliability
when reliability is an important piece
of the project
it builds a virtuous cycle your clients
so to speak
come to recognize ah yeah okay you've
done something really good
i want more of it and i want it on a
regular basis
they're gonna give you the time for that
i can guarantee that unless you're in an
unreasonable environment of course
that's the case
uh stick it out i and now's i would i
would oftentimes say
just quit but now there's not this is
not the economy for that
um because uh in a in a chooser's place
in the choosers market like a data
scientist market
yeah you i would just encourage you find
it find a better placement like
that organization doesn't really
understand data doesn't understand
and appreciate good practices um i'm not
sure you want to
spend your life being wasted on on
this kind of environment but in in this
in in this
day and age i think stick it out for the
time being hopefully there's
opportunities to be able to educate your
colleagues
on on these practices and why they're
important
okay and with that i like to go to the
final slide and say thank you for
listening my apologies i did go over
time
but there's been a lot on my in my head
and on my heart that i want to pour out
and make sure that data science teams
can really move
faster be more effective
have a lot more fun eliminate lots of
drudgery
and i want that all that good stuff for
you all right so now if you want to keep
in contact with me
my website is on the slides up there
so you can always check out what i'm up
to up there
and all the relevant links from my
website are
out there too so thank you very much
thanks also priyanka for being an
awesome
presentation controller thank you so
much and apologize i think i was moving
too slow and too fast
no no not at all not at all we didn't
even rehearse this so that that was
that was amazing that was really cool
all right i do see some
uh comments and questions yeah but
before that i just wanted to highlight
so tyler has just posted in the chat
about a google form which is for the
book raffle
so we would appreciate everyone signing
in
you know clicking on that link and going
ahead and showing their interest
so we have two books one is the book uh
the network analysis book that you
talked about and then the another one is
effective by charm
um so we will have in total of uh two
copies each
um so i should say four in total
and then yes uh now is the time for q a
we would have eric uh like you know
people
anybody can post questions on chat and
we would have eric answer them
one by one there was one question i
think that i also asked
um went off i don't know where so i
think my question was
um to begin with uh
do you do you have this structure so i
mean it
it looks like something that has evolved
for you or for
would it would evolve for anybody um but
how do you
um like how do you increa in
inculcate this habit in the beginning
like do you
already have like a basic structure that
you want to start with that you suggest
everyone should start with when you know
whether it's about folder structure or
readme
at the time of starting a new project or
is it okay to
you know keep adding folders and
notebooks and everything eventually
yeah um so let's see i think
if you take what's on the slides that's
a
very lightweight starting point so
there's a bunch of there one of the
slides inside there has like
everything that's relevant it's one of
the last slides in like one
the one to one to one to one mapping
slides um
that's a that's that's where my mental
model is and i i do know that
at least in my head i've memorized uh
notebooks
data source readme those four are like
the bare minimum plus my
environment.yaml file
uh and then everything else i can like
sort of build in as
the project complexity requires it and i
think um
who is it uh on andrea
uh pierre did uh make a comment that
cookie cutter is
like a little bit uh what do you call
fixed or it does it does
enforce too much once you stuck
to a structure i think that's that's the
point so
there's a cool tool called copier i
actually haven't heard of it so thank
you andrea for that
for sharing that um and i think it it
would
it's it's a great like the tools that
help us
automate these pieces are really great
as well
though i think at the same time we
probably want to
develop over time an awareness of
how yeah an awareness of like
what a scene structure and one could
maybe even say a taste
for what a scene structure would look
like right so for example
um user space notebooks wasn't something
that i originally had
until i realized i was going to work
with two or three other people
and that's when i thought oh well maybe
we should give user spaces
underneath the notebooks directory but
user spaces for source code doesn't
really make sense because
we're going to be sharing the source
code so there's no such concept as like
eric's functions
i mean my source dot pi right like we we
talk together
and try to make sure these functions are
well
organized in the source code and it's
actually been a few times i've got
really
great interns i'm so happy about them um
an intern comes in writes a function and
then i
a few months later i go back in the
source code like i
think there's got to be something
written that does exactly what i want
and
true enough arkady has written that
function and i don't have to
write it for myself and he's documented
it and he's tested it so i can like
completely
test trust that that function works
exactly as it is
so yeah that's um we we sort of build it
up
um and we work out together
what makes sense and i think the taste
of what makes sense is pretty common
amongst most people
so hopefully that answer your question
it does thank bianca um let's see
on had a question any tools for showing
dags uh
yes uh actually that's one of kedrow's
strengths
uh i haven't had that complexity yet
in my own projects but i do have
colleagues who who have it
and they swear by kedrow so uh
definitely check out kedro for
for that purpose um
and then another question from anne was
uh
do i have a tutorial that incorporates
all of these practices not yet but
i would love to write one hopefully
collaborate with others on it that's
part of the whole
trying to live out what i preach right
like you know do the open source
education thing teach people
help elevate the field um with these
open source materials that are
out there for teaching so yeah i'd love
to work together on that
and ann has another question exploratory
work with the end products not known
from the start
do i categorize them into exploratory
versus productionized deliverable ones
do i apply the same standards for both
right
right those are really great questions
and i can tell you uh it's an open
secret for me
that i have a scratch environment in
which i prototype things there is an
environment file for that
so uh it's pretty well defined and i
know that anything inside there is
guaranteed to work with each other
there's been like this exploratory
statistical methods paper that i've been
trying to get written
that started out actually inside the
scratch environment
and had zero structure like it was just
notebooks notebooks notebooks
if you look at the structure it was flat
there were a bunch of notebooks there
was a parquet file there was a csv file
there was a netcdf file there was python
scripts all in
in one place and it was a mess and
actually i i suffered when i sort of had
to drop that exploratory statistical
methods thing for a few months
and then come back to it it's only been
a few months
the only thing i could remember was
notebook five because i put
five dash something dot i pinb that was
the thing i was primarily working in
and everything else was a jumbled mess
okay that speaks to why
you would want to put same structure
from
for every project if possible but of
course if you're just like i'm acting on
inspiration
well be ready of course then mentally
ready
to pay the time necessary later on
for creating uh for for imposing
structure on it and and
you're g you're going to lose some
things in the process like i've lost
there's some scripts that i just don't
know how to connect to everything else
in the project they just go into this
dump they go into the folder called dump
and someday i'll look at it again if
it's ever relevant right
so i would say
encourage you to try to
um hold yourself to the same standards
for exploratory
and production as deliverable projects
um
but don't bang yourself up if you fail
to because
you know if you're in an okay
environment you'll have time to
worry about that later on um and
i think the other one is how often do we
refactor our code we i refactor code as
soon as i
copy paste it so as soon as i catch
myself
copy this code block and i'm just gonna
paste it inside the other notebook
yeah that's that's the time to like
refactor there are people who are not as
strict as i am
some will say i've gotta copy it three
times that's when i really know
i need it in multiple notebooks and so
then that's cool as well
um cesar has a question
when you should be pinning
oh uh cesar so in in chat so for the
benefit of those who are watching the
recording
do you have any preferred uh sorry uh
any recommendation for when you should
be pinning the version of your packages
my usual workflow is not to set up any
version create and then
pip freezer conda list then copy and
paste that in the conf file
is there a better way i don't know of
any better way that's exactly how i do
it
so you're you're you're like you're with
me i'm with you on that one
um and cesar has another question which
is what's the preferred package for
creating dashboards
been playing with streamlit but
wondering if i have some other
preferences
i've actually played with a large range
of them
streamlit is conceptually the easiest
but it's also i
found programming model wise the
it's the easiest to get up to something
that you can present
to others it's kind of a pain to
maintain long term
but then again building dashboards uh
or building i guess applications off you
know uh
data driven applications off um
uh i think that that really should be
we should be enlisting the the help of a
proper ui ux team
software development team data
scientists can
try and build the prototype stream
that's great for prototyping
and i've used that i've used panel as
well to just get prototypes out
i've actually had one experience it's an
automated chemistry machine learning
thing
[Music]
i built a prototype of what the front
end should look like it was enough
to shape up the project and now there's
like five or six engineers working on
on that with the product owner to
take that to production so streamless
great just start with that um
if you want something up really quickly
um
venkatash is asking as a remark viewing
the topic through the software
engineering lens diaz is going through a
knowledge consolidation phase as more
and more folks work on ds projects
and identify issues plus opportunities
to improve the data science workflow
so this is very similar to what software
engineering went through the
last two decades and led to books such
as the pragmatic programmer and i'm
totally with juventus i i think it's
super important that we get our workflow
practices in order
because then that will help with the
velocity of what we're going to do
and i really want to encourage everybody
to sort of develop a taste
for tooling that is um
that is lightweight enough to
incorporate into your workflow
but also able to provide a
multiple fold of benefits relative to
the
heaviness of that tool so develop a
taste for that and and don't be
too quick to develop things i'm kind of
i didn't
adopt these practices and tooling at one
shot
did incorporate them and try to make
sure that they they made sense in my
context
um so there's a few others um
there are a few other tools that have
shown up i know tyler's
saying we probably have to close up
right now um so
yeah i think i want to thank everybody
for coming
once again thanks again to the hosts of
the the meetup
zach have actually been at the meetup in
and then been through the uh ups and
downs that the pi data boston has been
um so uh hopefully hopefully there'll be
more time
in the future that i can come back and
and you know hear more great stuff from
everybody
awesome so we definitely want to give a
huge thank you to eric this was awesome
and definitely as
being in a company that's going through
some an analytic transformation i feel
like these practices are things i'll be
definitely taking back to my team and
sharing with them
uh so i'm excited to do that uh so big
thank you and i'm sure
be a big round of applause for all in
person uh one thing that i just want to
mention
kind of going off of that a few action
items for the
for the folks still on the call um
definitely sign up for our slack group
we want to stay connected and be able to
continue to drive and share ideas across
the group
um in addition to that take a look at
eric's stuff that he's able to share
definitely feel free to share his
content um continue to mention what you
liked about the talk
definitely we want to continue to grow
this group and um we definitely
appreciate everyone continuing to
participate and
and really leading to our last piece is
call for speakers we're always excited
to kind of push
other people's ideas and definitely get
behind them i think this was a great
talk and if you also agree
and you have another idea feel free to
come back
and folks feel free to continue to kind
of continue to build this community
um there's one more mention and i think
we mentioned a little bit earlier
um pi data is doing a global conference
it's going to be virtual
that's going to be super cool because
these conferences are usually located
like new york
some other cities so everyone's going to
be able to be part of this so um
huge huge opportunity for that um but
with that
again thank you eric this was awesome uh
and thanks everyone
for joining all right thank you
everybody
thank you eric and thank you everybody
bye